à la présidentielle où sa chaîne youtube
sur sa chaîne youtube fait la même
karine alors karine elle a fait ça et à
pompe et karine eux
je pense qu'elle a pompé d'autres
personnes mais pas moi c'est parce que
je voulais dire
alors bon c'est vrai que ça ben bernanke
qui peut deviner qu'un garçon il dit ça
ça aurait provoqué un scandale sur les
réseaux etc c'est une double attaque
d'abord c'est parce qu'elles pensent que
magali parce que à la une image un peu
superficielle tels apéros de s'exprimer
ces gens qui pensent que les milieux
autorisés s'autorise à penser c'est
absolument scandaleux c'est du mépris ça
me choque profondément et c'est vrai que
de dire à une femme à la pompe et
excusez moi c'est une violence extrême
c'est que c'est quoi le seront dans les
échos bague est bien là elle a aussi
pourquoi pascal et à la pompe et des
mecs mais dans quelle banque et dans
quelle vie on peut se faire une chose
pareille je trouve ça scandaleux c'est
pas drôle c'est humiliant c'est
rabaissant c'est un vrai scandale vous
devrez alors je vous dis
ça fait de la peine parce que c'est
gratuit en fait me faire attaquer j'ai
l'habitude moi ça me dérange pas et puis
c'est le jeu c'est pas grave les
critiques sont constructives mais après
ils ont ils ont qu'ils ont commencé par
dire oui elle fait pitié ils ont été
particulièrement violents et mes chances
que ça c'est vraiment que la fin d'une
interview fin de la rigolade là et puis
je trouvais sympa drôle et puis je suis
maman j'ai trois enfants je vais dire
c'est pas pourquoi enfin je veux dire
s'il faut respecter moi mes filles elles
vivent le cyberharcèlement ça fait cinq
ans que je fais ce métier sur les
réseaux sociaux c'est un métier qui est
très violent que j'ai subi que j'accepte
aussi mais il ya du venant d'une femme
comme ça surtout quand elle est mal
placé parce que quand elle a eu des
problèmes ou quand elle s'est sentie
attaque elle pour rien par exemple à
lyon pas mais kelly où elle s'est sentie
à attaquer pour rien puisque c'était
mignon plus quelques mois j'ai regardé
la vidéo l'autre jour geste est mignon
lcl lama fait tout un roman sur les
réseaux sociaux fait des années que nous
formons la tuer mais c'est ça et ça on
aurait dit ça d'elle ici avec tout le
bordel cas là
c'est sûr ça nous aurait soulevé
géraldine non mais moi en plus ce j'en
ai parlé à magali moi je n'aime pas tout
ce que tu fais mais j'ai trouvé que
justement ce programme youtube il est
juste génial il est très intéressant et
si ça doit prendre ne serait-ce qu'un
jeune allez allez oui on est là pour
parler mais c'est quand même alors il
parlait de la phrase oui mais d'après
moi le train soit c'est malhonnête
intellectuellement non d'ailleurs c'est
malhonnête intellectuellement c'est à
dire qu'en gros elle est jaloux de ce
que de ce que tu as fait parce que tu le
fais mieux qu'elle et parce que tu as
des réseaux donc ça c'est pas bien soit
les céder drôle effectivement là je suis
d'accord avec benjamin c'est sexiste et
c'est dégueulasse voilà donc que dans
les deux salles seulement vers
l'origine c'est grossier c'est même
injurieux et c'est d'une vulgarité est
incroyable on peut dire que c'était une
bonne voie la plus facile
attention là c'est une valeur dépasse le
cadre même d'un jugement de valeur le
dit pas comme une bonne
c'est vrai qu'il a dit je ne sais pas
qui est la bombe est vrai mais pas moi
c'est pas une vanne
pas tous en même temps avec des
sous-entendus glauque un guillaume au
delà de la pseudo vannes qui est
catastrophique face et quand même
profondément méprisant et les très mal
placé pour ça puisque elle même a été
jugé quand elle recevait des politiques
parce que c'était une animatrice qui
tirera sud et du divertissement donc au
lieu de faire ça devrait encourager
magali bardal faire plutôt que la
critique et la wii c'est ridicule et les
adhérents se moquer d'elle pour sa a
connu pas moi je suis avec ma femme on
je suis désolé mais je ne suis pas une
coureuse de faim je sais pas comment on
appelle ça le garçon que je qui a été
mariée pendant qu'un ton
aujourd'hui qui était une personne
lambda qui avec moi que j'aime ça se
passe bien enfin je vais dire tu mets ta
note
sentimentale non mais quand bien même
battu le chili avec fatou ça nous avait
privés on aurait eu des relations non
mais c'est pas le kelly non je trouve qu
on commence au fur et à mesure à voir
enfin le vrai visage de karine le
marchand bas ça me fait plaisir parce
qu'on entend beaucoup de trucs en off
mais là au moins on le montre d'elle
même à la télé donc je trouve ça plutôt
souhaite en même temps moi je trouve que
c'est un peu une guéguerre de
2-2-2 d'argentan de jalousie deux fois
là elle n'a pas 40 ans karine oui elle
est plus vieille oui à la 55 ans 50 sais
pas
mais en tout cas dans tous les cas je
trouve que c'est bien là que le bât
gallica 42 g de la mersey pour moi c'est
de la jalousie mal placée s'est montré
un petit peu son aigreur et son malheur
envers une femme qui est heureuse
épanouie faire son travail et gréements
qui se répondent moi je pense que moi là
comme vous avez dit cécile van cesse
mais ouais mais c'est pas dire jean luc
reichmann il revient derrière il sent
qu'il n'est pas dit comme ça c'est pas
de 10 ans vannes et moi j'aime pas que
j'aime pas les gens qui restent entre
genres mais on n'a pas droit de créer on
n'a pas lorsqu'on on aime ou on n'aime
pas ce que fait magali mais elle crée à
l'essaie attendent des choses et il ya
des gens qui regardent les gens qui
regardent ils existent vraiment les
millions de vues ne faut pas être jaloux
et j'aime pas quand tu oublie d'où tu
viens j'ai l'impression que karine le
marchand est fatigué on lui doit bien ça
encore pire elle sous-entend que magali
a là aussi en cochant et des mecs
étaient loin
matic essenza n'y a pas été jusque là
bas on n'a pas du tout les mêmes
concepts d'émissions déjà c'était
gratuit c'est pour ça que ça m'a blessé
aussi c'est parce qu'on fit on n'avait
même pas le même concept elle est un
père veuf des gens peu dans leur
intimité moi pas du tout selon laquelle
peut l'attaquer car le marchand de givry
ça peut être de l'injure publique tout
ça comment donc un peu l'attaqué voire
même de la diffamation parce qu un
sous-entendu donc il ya vraiment oui il
ya une possibilité d' attaque
j'encourage pas forcément
fait ce qu'elle veut
c'est vrai que ce qui s'est passé après
sinon ça va encore faire on parle ici
insultes publiques et diffamation vous
avez été choqué oui c'est choquant bien
sûr c'est surprenant à ce point je veux
dire en plus elle a connu ce problème là
au départ quand elle a commencé à
l'interviewer les politiques d'elle elle
même tout le monde disait ce monde-là
critiqués en disant qu'est-ce qu'elle
fait cette fille du divertissement je
suis très déplacé on sait que je viens
de d'attaqué magali là dessus toujours
au niveau gare le power on n'y est pas
du tout ça minable un minimum de 100
euros daniel alors moi je suis désolé
j'ai un tout petit peu tempéré c'est pas
bien du tout et c'est pas un mot que je
veux enfin vrai mais c'est quand même
reichmann qui sans intention
amoncellement de las vegas sans
connotation dit le mot pour mon ami
le roi gens pensent vraiment vous
cherchez des choses elle n'a pas dit
méchamment el hadi pour faire un bébé -
avec ces mots combien y
avait il n'y avait pas dit autre chose
l'envoyer qui avait cassé un grand
migros se met dans la sphère j'entends
perd gagne et que des mesures en saxe et
bien je tends à leers